all right so around two and a half years
ago I remember searching on the internet
trying to figure out how to start my own
Cloud Learning Journey at the time I
barely knew anything about the cloud and
it seemed like for every website I went
on people were recommending a different
Cloud course it was really confusing for
me and what ended up happening was I
jumped from resource to Resource trying
to figure out which one to use I did
eventually find some amazing courses to
learn AWS but all that Googling probably
wasn't the best use of my time fast
forward to today I've gotten 5 AWS
certifications I've spent two years at
AWS working as a Solutions architect and
now I run this YouTube channel where I
help people build their technical skills
and land a job in the cloud and so in
this video I'm going to share with you
the best free AWS Cloud courses I
recommend for beginners these resources
have been really useful for me and by
sharing them with you I want to help you
save some time and money when it comes
to choosing what course you should use
if you find this type of content helpful
please give this video a like and with
that being said let's jump straight into
Resource number one so the first free
AWS Cloud course I'd recommend is this
six hour Cloud practitioner Essentials
course this course is part of AWS skill
Builder which is a platform designed by
AWS for cloud Learners it's a
foundational level course for beginners
and helps you prepare for the AWS Cloud
practitioner exam in this course you'll
learn about AWS Cloud Concepts the core
AWS services and other Cloud topics like
security and pricing so whether or not
you end up paying the 100 USD to sit the
exam the course itself provides you with
a great foundational understanding of
AWS cloud and another reason I'd
recommend this course is because it's
created by AWS themselves if AWS makes
any major changes to their Cloud
offerings then they'll update the
courses to reflect those changes AWS
skill Builder also has a bunch of other
free courses like this mini course that
explains the different job roles
available in the cloud they do also have
Hands-On Labs where they provide you
with a Sandbox environment but that's
only offered in their paid subscription
plan if you're learning AWS and haven't
started using AWS skill builder at High
highly recommend signing up to a free
account and trying out their courses the
next resource I'd recommend is udemy
courses many people don't know this but
udemy doesn't just have paid courses
they actually have an entire library of
free courses and tutorials with free
courses they don't provide a certificate
or instructor support but you'll be able
to access the online video content for
free you can see here that they have a
AWS Zero to Hero course a cloud
competing with AWS course and even a
career focused course to help you start
your career with AWS all three of these
are completely free and there are many
more AWS courses available that don't
cost you anything I'll leave links down
below to some of these free udemy
courses if you'd like to check them out
at this point you might be like Lucy I'm
kind of sick of watching video courses
is there a more engaging way to learn if
you're in that situation I'd recommend
AWS cloudquest it's pretty much an
online game that teaches you about AWS
Cloud but what's really good about
cloudquest is that it helps you build
skills through Hands-On exercises and
activities where you actually get to to
work with AWS services so as a player
you enter a virtual City and choose a
role like Solutions architect and you
complete missions tailored towards the
role and by the end of it you receive a
digital badge that you can showcase on
LinkedIn I haven't played Cloud Quest
myself because it didn't exist back then
around two years ago when I first
started learning cloud but my 16 year
old sister has and she really enjoyed it
and learned a lot from the game there
are also some other ways you can learn
AWS without having to watch video
courses and one of them is by doing AWS
workshops and Hands-On Labs as I've
mentioned in many of my previous videos
I really believe that the best way to
learn cloud computing is by playing
around with the services if you're new
to AWS Cloud make sure you check out
these two websites that feature over a
hundred step-by-step guided AWS
tutorials a common question I get asked
is Lucy I know many of these tutorials
are available for free but does it cost
anything for me to use AWS Services the
good news is AWS does have a free tier
for certain services so you can
experiment and learn without incurring a
high cost but you do have to be aware of
what's free and what isn't so make sure
you take a look at this page before you
start building things in your AWS
console before we move on to the next
free course I'd like to take a moment to
tell you about today's video sponsor
guardio because so much of our lives are
online these days it's important to know
that super common cyber scams can be
accessed through our browsers and
threaten our security and information
and that's where guardio comes in it's
an easy to use browser extension that
acts as an online bodyguard protecting
users as they browse online it detects
it blocks scams before they reach your
browser to make sure you do it fall
victim to cyber crimes so what does
guardio actually do it identifies and
blocks phishing attacks malicious
downloads and websites it also removes
pop-ups and ads that may lead to scams
and it helps protect your online
identity and sensitive data here's a
quick demo of how Guardia Works download
the extension sign up for an account and
then you'll be able to scan a device for
any existing risks or data leaks after
your scan you can start a seven day free
trial remove threats and have real-time
24 7 protection by the way one account
includes seven members so you can make
sure everyone in your family is safe
online cardio isn't just another Chrome
extension It's featured by Google and
has over a million users so to see
guardio in action and scan your browser
for free head to guard.io forward slash
Tech with Lucy now let's get back to the
video another free course I'd recommend
is this AWS Cloud practitioner
certification course taught by Andrew
Brown on the free code Camp YouTube
channel if you don't want to sign up for
any accounts and just want to start
learning cloud straight away then I'd
suggest watching this 13 hour course
directly through YouTube I've watched
the entire course end to end back when I
was first starting to learn cloud and
what I liked about it was that there
were a lot of demos and diagrams that
made it easier for me to understand new
Cloud Concepts the final resource I'd
like to share is free live trading
provided by AWS this is something I
haven't seen shared around very much but
AWS actually provides instructor-led
training completely for free anyone can
attend and they have cloud training days
as well as exam Readiness sessions to
help you pass AWS certification exams
for example you can see that they have
this AWS Cloud practitioner Essentials
day that's five hours long and provides
a detailed overview of cloud Concepts
AWS Services security architecture
pricing and support So if you're looking
for free training I'll leave a link down
below to the AWS training and
certifications events page okay so now
that I've shared with you the top three
resources to learn AWS I'd highly
recommend watching this AWS
certification roadmap video where I
share a step-by-step roadmap on how you
can start your AWS certification Journey